Keanu and I were talking about this
recently trying to patch it together
he's got a better memory than I do mine
is all effed up but
um he's like that brother you have the
like correctionals I'm like I remember
when he's like no actually what we did
was blah blah
um
no but he was like his memory I think
was that they called us into Interscope
and then they told us there and I do
remember I've told the story a trillion
times so it's not fresh anymore but I do
remember vividly that day of being in
the office as an Interscope and I knew I
had the part and Keanu was all forlorn
and we'd kind of become friends by then
because we'd been auditioning for so
long and he played the Basin Road
motorcycle and I played the basement
motorcycle he just became buddies but uh
he was all for long I was like what's
your problem he's like well I'm playing
Ted and I thought it was Bill you know
and I was like dude there was honest to
God there was no [ __ ] difference
between these two characters I'm happy I
I'm more than happy to swap well he's
like no no it's cool that's also very
generous
like that's good I'm good I'm good
um but uh but I think that's when we
kind of got told yeah wow and house
again did you know that this was did you
think okay this is something special
I just know Lost Boys was the movie
where I was like wow I'm in a big hit
movie with this giant director and like
you know Jason was amazing and kiefers
have made like these actors who were so
good and I came from New York theater
and so I knew Ed Herman already I've
done yeah Manhattan theater Club I knew
Ed I knew Diane a little bit I knew
Bernard Hughes from the New York theater
scene I was just like these were Titans
of like New York Theater which was my
scene I was like what the [ __ ] are they
even doing here you know in this movie
with the oiled up sax player and
um so no I on Lost Boys I was like wow
this is Hollywood yeah like I'm in a
Hollywood movie you know and I'd be
doing scenes with Keith and I'd be like
God he's [ __ ] great you know he's
like he's gonna be a giant movie star
yeah and of course he was
um bilater was like the Opera wow I was
like yeah I don't know I'd be like dude
we'd be like literally waiting for a
take to start looking to be like no
one's ever gonna see this [ __ ] movie
you thought that no one is ever in a
million years ever gonna see this
[ __ ] movie and we had a BL like we
didn't disparage it like we were having
it we tried you kicked out we were like
but like Steve's in his 20s and the
writers are in their 20s and like no one
gave it was this weird Indie movie that
no one gave a [ __ ] about it and no one
in town knew about it was low budget and
it was like you get paid much we didn't
get paid hardly I got paid 65 000 for
Dylan's head for three months before
before commission and tax and everything
I think I I think that money was spent
like on paying back my student loans
buff and didn't touch my rent right
um so it was like this is great we're
having we put our all into it we had fun
acting yeah we cared about it we thought
the writing was [ __ ] awesome we
thought Steve was great but we didn't
think it was the era of HBO like we were
like this is going to be on HBO at like
four in the morning like this is going
to be sandwiched between like some TNA
horror movie goodbye Emmanuel exactly
yeah no one is ever and then sure enough
the movie the movie got scrapped so we
recall we we got a call from Scott the
producer going it's just like after we
made it after they put it post like
sorry guys but no one's ever gonna see
this film it's being shelved and we were
like oh okay
and I went did a little like period oops
holy [ __ ] sorry it's the ghost of uh of
Dino De Laurentiis I went and did this
little movie in Italy
um after that with Laura Dern and Eric
Stoltz
and they were like and we shot some of
the same locations we just done Bill and
Ted we've shot in the same castle that I
did the the Darth Vader fight with and
now I'm like playing this you know 19th
century strange character with like in
these fineries and all of the Bill and
Ted signs were up and and they were like
what is this [ __ ] movie I was like no
one's ever gonna see this film right
um and it got shelved and it sat on a
shelf for a year and then it got bought
out at like in a fire sale by Nelson and
then then it became a hit so it was a
very not Hollywood not we're gonna make
it
trajectory and it wasn't until the
release weekend when there was like a
two-fold ad and variety that showed me
and Keanu sitting on top of piles of
cash and it was like Bill and Ted giant
hit or whatever the wording was and I
was like oh okay but it took all the way
up until then to think it was gonna have
any kind of life